right first the herb butter for the
seminar crews are you ready yes good my
darling yeah spatula oh good there we
are
holy butter no butter yeah into the bowl
yeah oh yes yes
now from there we'll get some herbs from
deal okay right now push the deal
together okay okay now just trim it just
just let your voices you're cheating
you're trimming sort of your head
rodebush now get some basil leaves
okay now this put your like okay pinch
them up together yeah and roll them up
like a cigar smoke it yes that's it good
straining I start great good girl now
wacky backy from there no touch of salt
and pepper sauce yeah now everybody grab
your lemons okay we're gonna make this
butter okay
the grater yeah lemon lemon please come
on patty now watch those knuckles turn
and great the idea now is to get the
zest in there right Ian in Surrey how's
your lemon how is it yeah no great great
great
wakey-wakey there
it's a horse what is that right kitchen
here we go so you think it looks a bit
old for a little pony no a man of his
age now mix that butter up is really
important that we use the back of the
spatula the idea here of course it's
almost bruising the herbs to get this
amazing scented butter okay good